speak to mark dow a professor of
communications at the american
university of beirut thanks for joining
us mark
at the end of the day i spoke to zaina
about this the lebanese people want
accountability and justice and are they
likely ever to get that now given what's
unfolded on the streets this morning
uh it's obvious that that is a very
difficult road eventually they will get
there but what's standing in front of
them and facing them off
is basically militias militias with
weapons who
attempt to undermine government by
threatening to leave government
whose security agency officers
visit the courthouse and issue threats
to judges and then leak them to the
press and third they mobilize people in
the streets with weapons with
rocket launchers and automatic machine
guns and fire at homes and instigate
fights within the peaceful streets of
beirut all to prevent
ministers who have been accused and
already indicted in corruption through
international sanctions that have been
imposed on them all of this six people
died today several tens of people
injured a lot of destruction all because
two corrupt ministers
do not want to attend a hearing
with the judge who has accused them of
negligence for their performance when
they were ministers
and when those ammonium nitrates that
exploded in lebanon the third biggest
non-nuclear explosion in the history of
mankind those people don't want to even
show up to the investigation they are
both
now
uh uh
running away from justice they are uh
out there and they're trying to protect
themselves with armed protesters
unfortunately
it has caused six people to die because
two corrupt politicians don't want to
show up so yes justice is on the right
course the illegal attempts at
undermining and removing the judge have
both times failed the third one is going
to be through political pressure and
thus they have went through
terrorizing the streets and increasing
pressure on the government that they
have and there was
leaks from the minutes of the meeting of
the ministers and the minister of
culture who is a hezbollah and partisan
he basically said you either take a
political and legal decision to remove
the judge which is an intervention by
the executive power into the judicial
power or we will no longer allow this
government to meet
and he threatened the entire government
including the president of the country
the prime minister and everyone else and
that is where it stopped political
pressure and now the government is in
limbo this government that is supposed
to be doing something to alleviate the
economic situation and the hardships in
lebanon just got itself again
held hostage by hezbollah their arms
their militias in the street in politics
because they participate in the
government only to protect the interests
of iran and their militias and their
interventions in syria and other places
justice in lebanon is not a priority for
them it is always a conspiracy theory to
try and undermine them on twitter and
other social media their partisans today
are saying that this judge just became
the beach head for the u.s intervention
into lebanese politics another lie
creating another fake conspiracy theory
to try and undermine justice the rule of
law the government and the entire state
of lebanon there should be a firm
response from the government there
should be a call for a meeting
immediately for the government and it
should take steps to protect judge
justice and the independence of the
judiciary the judge today got the right
ruling which is the ruling that he can
continue to perform his duties
against the
attempt of the ministers to remove him
he is back on his job tomorrow morning
and they should show up to the court of
justice and he has every right to arrest
them
mark given the political situ this the
political system rather what does the
future hold for lebanon how do we
escape the cycle of so-called corruption
uh
going forward
i believe that process is about a
complete reform uh we cannot reform this
country with the same people who got us
into this mess we cannot reform the
country with
militias
independently from the state operating
their own foreign policy opening their
own wars and then dictating what happens
in terms of the operation of the
security the judiciary and others so
this requires a formal reform and this
is a demand on the president the prime
minister and everyone who is in the
state as well as the opposition to this
governed government that they need to
stand to protect the state from the
militias
hezbollah is the main organization
undermining the state the only way that
will happen it will not happen by any
international intervention there are
deals happening all across the region
between the french the americans are
withdrawing from the region so it's down
to lebanese local political parties to
stand and say we want to run this
country
based on the constitution and the laws
no longer by force of weapons therefore
what is needed now is reform and
reformists who are supporting the
functioning of the state the explosion
the investigation is a real test if that
logic can rule or again lebanon falls
into the trap of being ruled by a gun by
a militia for the purpose of serving
iran's interest in lebanon
mark certainly reform is an uphill
challenge for the country and you're
saying that it needs to be lebanese-led
but surely the international community
can put pressure on the government what
would you be hoping or what do you think
the international international
community is viewing or how do you think
they're viewing what's unfolded today
i believe they realized that it is not
enough to do economic reform when they
say reforms it has to be political
reforms and pushing forward withholding
parliamentary elections and municipal
elections in the coming six months seven
months is extremely important in
addition to that they need to realize
that if they leave
ministers who have already been
sanctioned by the u.s unsanctioned by
europe unsanctioned by other
international organizations those
ministers will keep on fighting even
violently then and their political
parties to stop the government from
moving forward or reforming thus putting
pressure on those individuals the
individuals responsible for the call of
protest with arms that led to the death
of six people and instigating fights
between christians and the shiite
community today the international
community is called upon
to accuse those individuals and take
sanctions the european parliament
previously a few months ago took a
decision on a framework and then voted
within the european parliament
on the entire framework for sanctions on
lebanese politicians for their
obstruction of justice or corruption now
is the time to start applying those
sanctions on those individuals because
if they don't put a limit and they cost
to their actions they're willing to get
us down to blood and war again to
maintain their power and to undermine
the state so the international community
needs to be extremely fair with those
political parties that have mobilized
militants with arms today and have taken
action they need to be sanctioned and
they need to be condemned
mark i'm really getting a sense of your
anger here
do you think that reflects the broader
lebanese community i mean is this going
to reignite the anger amongst the
lebanese
i was born in the 70s
and my parents used to hide me in
alleyways away from bombs and guns in
the lebanese civil war
today what we're mostly seeing and what
is really disturbing is we saw students
in those areas being
in put in hiding by their teachers from
bullets and bombs around them seeing
that is a terrifying experience another
generation being hid in alleyways and in
parkings and in basements again we don't
deserve this
they need to be stopped and we need to
find them now before this spreads and
hezbollah and their arms and the
militias again dominate a country for
their political power and not for the
governance or the benefit of the
lebanese people i think everyone in
those streets and neighborhoods that
were fighting today they know that they
are on a barrel about to explode they
need to step up they need to protect
their lives and the government and the
army need to be there for them until we
contain this and we blunt the attack and
the assault by hezbollah on the
judiciary this is the battle we need to
fight to avoid seeing our kids in
basements again
mark a lot of our audience is from
outside of lebanon can you get a sense
or give us a sense of what it's like to
live there now you know facing these
vast economic pressures uh the beirut
port explosion and the sense of death
that's happened over the last year or so
give us a sense of what it's like to
live in lebanon now and where you hope
the future lies
we are in a complete siege our money is
stuck in the banks
electricity is only provided for two
hours everything else is backup
generators
the costs of living have skyrocketed
because
the income and the currency has fallen
to bits and pieces
most people barely work
they just show up but there's nothing to
do
and now with the deterioration in the
security situation which already has
been through increase of thefts of
attacks of assaults and now
gunfights
this is we're besieged in our daily
lives in on every level economic social
and everything else people are sticking
to their homes doing the basics there is
no hope in the future they're just
hoping that tomorrow they'll be safe
that is how bad the situation is in
lebanon and then we've got the biggest
numbers of youth and capable individuals
emigrating
double-digit numbers of our healthcare
workers have left half businesses have
closed so
we're in very bad shape and yet
arms continue
to slaughter us in the streets because
they want to fight political battles
using the blood of innocent people in
the streets
returning to that conflict this morning
the interior minister says those who
prepared for the demonstration assured
us that it would be peaceful and the
shooting began with snipers taking aim
at people's heads what do you make of
his comments that they were assured that
it would be a peaceful demonstration
that would be an excellent line and a
stand-up comedy he knows hezbollah
except if he just came to the country
yesterday
i think his statement is a cover-up for
hezbollah and amal and he should be
condemned for that not only that he's an
active judge who asked to be part of
this government and conditioned that he
goes back to
the
judge role that he has this person is an
employee of the government who's
performing a role for
the current term just to have the title
i think it's more respectful for those
who died that he from the start is
responsible also for the protest and
what happens because his role as
minister of interior is to protect
people and he failed the least he could
have done after six people dying
being unable to protect homes and the
protest and everything if he had any
sense of decency as a judge or a human
he would have resigned and left home
instead he gave that funny ridiculous
statement which is a shame for a person
like him in that position to say after
people have died in the streets
how do you see the next hours and days
unfolding do you think that you are
likely to see that reform that you are
so desperately after
i think the fight now is to see if this
government can contain the onslaught the
second thing to watch out for is to see
judge bittar if he's going to continue
within his investigation
third is to see
movements and protest movements by
people especially the families of the
victims of whole those who died in the
august fourth explosion their actions
and how they're going to act because if
there are people in the streets if
there's a political fight and judicial
fight is on then yes the path of reform
is still open and we can move forward
and those are the three things i'll be
keeping an eye on speaking of one of
those things the investigation surely
now it's no longer
able to continue given what's happened
this morning and the pressure on the
judge how do you see it an internal
investigation unfolding surely it now
needs to go to perhaps an external party
to investigate
the process has already started within
the lebanese judiciary an external party
to investigate has to take the decision
by the government the government
currently is controlled by hezbollah the
prime minister is their ally i don't see
any international investigation coming
neither through a un security council
decision like the international tribunal
for the hariri assassination back in
2005 nor this current government with
michelle on as president miyati as prime
minister will do anything to upset
hezbollah that much they are his cronies
and i believe our best shot is still
protecting the lebanese investigation in
the short term if that fails we have no
recourse but to go for an international
investigation but that requires
international endorsement and i don't
think the countries such as france or
others
really have that as a priority for
themselves again the burden is on the
lebanese to fight the militias the
nonchalance of the international
community and an ability to protect the
judge and the legal system to withhold
the assault of hezbollah and their
weapons
well we appreciate your insights there
mark dao a professor of communications
at the american university of beirut
appreciate your time
thank you